wow 50 years of bad federal judicial
precedent has been overturned well
somebody sound the alarm you're not
supposed to be thinking with your finger
in the wind how do i best uphold the
legitimacy of my institution that is
what undercuts your legitimacy which is
why justice roberts is actually a
terrible terrible justice
so the big news of the day
is of course that the supreme court has
not immediately enjoined a texas state
law that effectively prevents abortion
after six weeks of pregnancy
and the reason the supreme court did
this is because of procedural mechanics
here so basically the supreme court
ruled
and the ruling was it was a five to four
ruling with of course chief justice
roberts joining the dissenters it was
the the republican appointees on one
side and then roberts with the liberals
on the other and the basic scheme of the
texas law is why the law was not
immediately taken up by the supreme
court so normally in order for you to
have a
lawsuit that is taken up by an appeals
court or taken up by the supreme court
you have to have somebody to sue right
just because you see something wrong in
life does not mean that you get to sue
and the person that you sue has to be
the right person and if you're suing
over a law presumably if you sue for
example the the person who is enforcing
the law that person has to have the
power to enforce the law so for example
in in roe versus wade it was an official
of government who was being sued in roe
versus way because it was that person's
responsibility to enforce the law so
that person ends up as the defendant
this is usually the case when you have a
case that's appealed to the supreme
court and it has to do with the law that
is being enforced by the state usually
there's some official whose name you
don't know who ends up as the defendant
in that particular lawsuit well texas
found a way around this at least for the
moment it's sort of a creative way
around this the way that they wrote the
law it is not that the texas state
government is going to be enforcing the
law it's not like somebody comes to your
door and takes you off to jail if you
participate in in the abortion process
at 12 weeks of pregnancy instead what
the texas state law basically did is it
created a private right of action
the private right of action essentially
allows anyone to sue a person in court
who has participated in the facilitation
of an abortion according to politico
individuals found to have violated that
law would have to pay ten thousand
dollars to the person who successfully
brings such a lawsuit it's almost sort
of a private bounty in other words so
let's say that there's a woman who wants
an abortion i know her abortion doctor
is providing her an abortion i can sue
the abortion doctor for providing her an
abortion at 10 weeks and then he has to
pay me 10 000 for his violation of the
law
according to politico anti-abortion
groups in the states such as texas
rights life have in recent weeks set up
tip lines for people to anonymously
report violators ahead of the law's
implementation earlier on tuesday a
federal district court issued a
temporary restraining order
barring the group from filing suits
against a small group of individuals and
organizations that assist patients in
obtaining an abortion but both sides of
the case acknowledge the order is very
narrow and the anti-abortion group said
it still plans to solicit tips and bring
lawsuits against abortion providers now
that the courts have given a green light
to the law's implementation so the
supreme court majority does not say
whether the law is constitutional they
just say that it is not clear whether
they can take up the case because
there's nobody to sue yet right nobody
has actually brought a lawsuit along
these lines as of yet so the supreme
court found
to prevail in an application for a stay
or an injunction an applicant must carry
the burden of making a strong showing
that is likely to succeed on the merits
and that will be irrevocably injured
absent to stay and that the balance of
equities favors it and that it stays
consistent with the public interest the
applicants now before us have very
serious questions regarding the
constitutionality of the texas law at
issue but their application also
presents complex and novel antecedent
procedural questions on which they have
not carried their burden so this is the
supreme court saying listen we might not
strike down roe versus wade we might in
fact strike down this law but first you
have to go through the actual procedure
of somebody having been grievously
harmed by a private actor in this
particular way because this lawsuit was
again directed at a person austin reeve
jackson who's a judge
it's directed at a person who actually
does not have the power to even enforce
the law per se
so says the majority
federal courts enjoy the power to enjoin
individuals tasked with enforcing laws
not the laws themselves it is unclear
whether the name defendants in this
lawsuit can or will seek to enforce the
texas law against the applicants in a
manner that might permit our
intervention the state has represented
that neither it nor its executive
employees possess the authority to
enforce the texas law either directly or
indirectly nor is it clear whether under
existing precedent this court can issue
an injunction against state judges asked
to decide a lawsuit under texas law
which is the person who was sued in this
particular case finally the sole private
citizen responded before us has filed an
affidavit stating he has no present
intention to enforce the law in light of
such issues we can't say the applicants
have met their burden to prevail in an
injunction or stay application okay then
there were the descents and then it
sends justice roberts didn't say that he
would vote to uphold roe versus way he
just said that he put an injunction on
the law pending some sort of resolution
of the underlying issues there's the
procedural issues and then there's the
underlying issue which is really the one
at the heart of the case which is is it
constitutional to pass a law that bars
abortion after weak sex now
look from a from a pure constitutional
perspective the answer of course is it's
fully constitutional for the vast
majority of america's history their
abortion laws in virtually every state
and obviously there is no right to an
abortion in the constitution of the
united states you can't point to it you
can't point to anything that points to
it it is emanations and penumbras and an
idiotic supreme court majority in roe
versus wade that literally created a
right to abortion out of whole cloth i
mean he's just created fully and just
sits there like a like a turd at the
bottom of the toilet bowl that's how bad
that decision it is a terrible decision
even people who are advocates of
abortion generally recognize that roe
versus wade is not a good legal decision
they just like the outcome
okay so as a matter of just what's in
the constitution on the underlying issue
the answer is of course texas can pass
this law and california can also pass a
law that allows abortion up till a
particular point maybe beyond depending
on exactly what exactly california is
doing and whether the 14th amendment and
the and the due process clause and the
equal protection clause applies to the
unborn right there's a strong pro-life
case that the equal protection clause
right that everyone is entitled to equal
protection of the law so far as life
liberty and uh and due process for
example that those
that that should include the unborn
right this is the pro-life case that if
you are a baby in the womb you don't get
to be killed just because you're a baby
in the womb or you're an independent
human life are protected by the
constitution of the united states but
putting that aside if you if if that is
not the argument that is going to be
accepted by the supreme court for
example which it seems would be unlikely
if that's not going to be the argument
accepted by the supreme court the
overturning of roe versus wade would not
lead to a vast national ban on abortion
it would lead to significant
restrictions in places like texas places
like georgia places like florida it
would lead to no restrictions in places
like california because it would just
get kicked back to the states that was
the situation before roe versus wade
there were very few restrictions on
abortion in blue states and there were
lots of restrictions on abortion in red
states
okay so chief justice roberts says you
know i'm not going to even tell you how
i'm voting on the underlying issue by
the way the majority said the same thing
here roberts just says that he would
enjoin it anyway so robert says the
statutory scheme before the court is not
only unusual but unprecedented the
legislature has imposed a prohibition on
abortions after roughly six weeks and
then essentially delegated enforcement
of that prohibition to the populace at
large the desired consequence appears to
be to insulate the state from
responsibility for implementing and
enforcing the regulatory regime the
state defendants argue they cannot be
restrained from enforcing their rules
because they're not enforcing them in
the first place i would grant
preliminary relief to preserve the
status quo ante before the law went into
effect so that the courts may consider
whether a state can avoid responsibility
for its laws in such a manner
defendants argue existing doctrines
preclude judicial intervention and they
may be correct
but the consequences of approving the
state action both in this particular
case and as a model for action in other
areas council at least preliminary
judicial consideration before the
program devised by the state takes
effect so roberts is fully admitting in
his own descent here that defendants may
be right that they are allowed to to
avoid culpability here because they're
not the actual defendants but justice
roberts says i'm going to intervene
anyway because i prefer the status quo
ante which is pure roberts right roberts
is mostly interested in preserving what
he perceives as judicial legitimacy at
the expense of actual judicial accuracy
and this is why he'll rewrite the
obamacare law in order to ensure that
obamacare remains the law of the land
despite the fact that it clearly
violates constitutional provisions and
separation of powers
right because justice roberts is always
thinking of the legitimacy of the by the
way because he thinks like this he's
completely undermined the legitimacy of
the institution it turns out the only
way to uphold the legitimacy of your
institution is to strictly interpret the
rules under which we are all supposed to
live so that there is predictability to
those rules you're not supposed to be
thinking with your finger in the wind
how do i best uphold the legitimacy of
my institution that is what undercuts
your legitimacy at least it's true as a
human being as well if you're constantly
vacillating because you're trying to
please people people don't like you as
much people think you're illegitimate
people don't trust you
and this is certainly true when it comes
to institutions which is why justice
roberts is actually a terrible terrible
justice in any case
he continues i would accordingly
preclude enforcement of sb8 by the
respondents to afford the district court
and the court of appeals the opportunity
to consider the propriety of judicial
action and preliminary relief pending
consideration of the plaintiff's claims
because basically his his argument is
that this
it upsets life too much if we don't if
we don't intervene it upsets life too
much then there are the actual liberals
on the court and their descent is
basically we love abortion and
abortion's in the constitution and this
is a bad law and so we should strike
down the law forget about the procedure
the law needs to go because the reality
is that imminent and serious harm are on
their way and we need to we need to make
sure that the quote unquote right to
abortion is preserved right this is the
descent
there's one from justice breyer there's
another one from justice sotomayor
sotomayor of course is the most uh vocal
ardent and uh and
screedlike uh she writes the most
screeds on the left of the court she
sort of replaced justice ginsburg in
that respect she says the court's order
is stunning presented with an
application to enjoin a flagrantly
unconstitutional law engineered to
prohibit women from exercising their
constitutional rights and evade judicial
scrutiny a majority of justices have
opted to bury their heads in the sand
okay it's not flagrantly
unconstitutional roe versus wade is
flagrantly anti-constitutional it is a
made-up law out of whole cloth pulled
directly from the colons of the justices
in that case particularly harry blackman
but
she says this is blatantly
unconstitutional which is a laugh since
her actual care about the constitution
is basically zero says last night the
court silently acquiesced in a state's
enactment of a law that flowed to nearly
50 years of federal precedence wow 50
years of bad federal judicial precedent
has been overturned well somebody sound
the alarm because it turns out the court
has routinely done that in cases where
they've made bad mistakes before namely
plessy versus ferguson or dred scott
she says today the court belatedly
explains it declined to grant relief
because of procedural complexities of
the state's own invention because the
court's failure to act rewards tactics
designed to avoid judicial review and
inflicts significant harm on the
applicants and on women seeking abortion
in texas i
dissent wow okay so that is where things
stand now
a lot of people in the media are reading
this as though the supreme court of the
united states is now going to knock down
rovers away i have serious doubts
whether the supreme court of the united
states is going to knock down rovers
away i think what they may do is rewrite
the planned parenthood versus casey
standard
which is a really really bad standard
the actual standard that may be curbed
here is the so-called undo burden
standard under planned parenthood versus
casey so the roe vs wade decision sets
up this ridiculous anti-scientific
trimester system right where the idea is
that you could have some restrictions in
the last trimester maybe a few
restrictions in the second trimester and
no restrictions in the first trimester
and then it sets up a standard of
viability and it says well until the
baby's viable you can basically do what
you want
none of this is in the constitution of
course it's absurd it's just made up
completely then
in the early 90s there's a case written
by sandra day o'connor and anthony
kennedy and that whole clan and the the
basic
idea of the case is that
the woman must never be unduly burdened
right she can't be on that is the undue
burden standard
that a woman cannot
have to face down in order that has the
purpose or effect of placing a
substantial obstacle in the path of a
woman seeking the abortion of a
non-viable fetus
okay and it's a mess i mean that
decision is a complete absolute mask
there's a plurality decision
okay so a majority found that that a
particular law was unconstitutional
four justices wrote or joined opinions
saying roe versus white should have been
struck down two justices wrote opinions
favoring the preservation of a higher
standard of review of review for
abortion restrictions it's a complete
mess
right it's it's just a complete and
utter just bleep show
no question
the undue burden standard is what ends
up emerging from this right you can't
put an undue burden on a woman's right
or ability to get an abortion now the
question is that's really vague what
actually constitutes an undue burden
where does that come from
okay so the court has been very unclear
about this sometimes they'll say that
something is an undue burden sometimes
they'll say it's not an undue burden
again the notion that an abortion is a
is a right to begin with is patently
crazy i mean that is there's nothing in
the constitution that guarantees such a
right there's nothing in natural law
that guarantees such a right there like
this where does this right come from it
basically came full blown from the heads
of a bunch of left-leaning justices on
the supreme court
but
it has now become a rote part of sort of
leftist theology and it really is of
theology at this point that abortion is
an inerrant good
abortion is itself excellent
and so you see people on the left
consistently making this argument
now i just want to point out that by six
weeks of pregnancy the baby is already
starting to develop like a lot okay like
the levels of development at this point
in time
are pretty high so you keep hearing from
people well you know most women don't
know that they're even pregnant by week
six of the pregnancy
well i mean they've already missed a
period so there's that but beyond that
there actually is some pretty
significant development like the notion
that this is just a cluster of
undifferentiated cells at this point is
just not true
according to the mayo clinic which is
not a right-wing site last i checked
they say week six the neural tube closes
growth is rapid this week just four
weeks after conception the neural tube
along your baby's back is closing the
baby's brain and spinal cord will
develop from the neural tube the heart
and other organs are also starting to
form and the heart begins to beat this
according to the mayo clinic now you'll
hear from people on the left well it's
not really the heart because the entire
heart hasn't been developed yet it's
just the it's it's the poles that will
become the heart that are firing
electrical signals
okay and
like really so
structure is necessary to the formation
of the eyes and ears develop small buds
appear that will soon become arms your
baby's body begins to take on a c-shaped
curvature in week seven the baby's head
develops
the baby's brain and face are growing
depressions that eventually give rise to
nostrils become visible the beginnings
of the retinas form lower limb buds that
will become legs appear the arm buds
that sprouted last week now take on the
shape of paddles week eight you've
already got a nose for the baby the
fingers have begun to form small
swellings outlined outlining the future
shaped parts of your baby's ears develop
the eyes become obvious the upper lip
and nose have formed the trunk and neck
begin to straighten again we are eight
weeks in
according to the left you should be able
to abort like pretty much all the way up
to birth there are no limiting
principles for the left but fetal
development is extraordinarily rapid
and pretty well developed certainly by
the time you hit the first trimester for
sure
okay but according to the left this is
just texas is evil and texas is terrible
and texas is a disaster
and there's an article after article
about this gayle collins says texas is
trying to overturn roe versus wade all
by itself
she says texas and of course you get the
obligatory
you get
this just amuses me you get the
obligatory photo of the women in the
handmaid's tale outfits
okay now just quick note you can get an
abortion pretty much anywhere in the
country that ain't texas also quick note
the the woman in the photo is wearing a
a pride progress
face mask a transgender right face mask
with a gay pride flag rainbow flag over
her face in the new york times photo
that has been chosen
and um this has become part of the
broader left-wing rubric where they just
create mad libs that don't make any
sense when it comes to these issues
right so what they like to say the the
original left-wing argument was safe
legal and rare right it's sad but it's
necessary in some cases we'd like to
make those cases less necessary but you
know where a woman is having a really
tough time we can't we can't burden her
he has a bad argument
but at least had some semblance of
morality attached to it then we went
from safe legal and rare to abortion is
the greatest thing that ever happened
and now we've moved all the way to
abortion is a woke issue that affects
the intersectional coalition which is
like the weakest pro-abortion argument
of all at least the secondary argument
that a woman needs to abort her baby so
she can be successful in her career
which is sort of the argument you'll see
made routinely by pro-abortion advocates
at least that argument
acknowledges the the logical consistency
of i need to kill this baby so that i
can get the promotion that's you know
pretty cruel and terrible but at least
it acknowledges it
when it gets enmeshed in the entire
intersectional woke rhetoric it makes no
sense at all it just starts to be
self-contradictory and very silly right
when you're declaring that men can be
women and it's very difficult to explain
how this is a woman's right issue when
you're when you're calling women
pregnant people
very difficult to explain why this is a
quote-unquote women's issue as opposed
to just you know a broad issue that
affects both women and men and all the
rest my favorite line of this and this
is why i point out the the gay pride
flag this person is wearing while
wearing the handmaid's tale outfit
is again once it gets enmeshed in the
left-wing mad lib it starts to make no
sense so corey bush this is just a great
example of this she tweets out yesterday
the congresswoman from missouri the
black lives matter congresswoman from
missouri says i'm thinking about the
black brown low-income queer and young
folks in texas the folks this abortion
healthcare ban will disproportionately
harm
wealthy white folks will have the means
to access abortion care our communities
won't okay so one of the arguments that
is consistently made by people on the
left is that black and brown women need
to have lots of abortions it is
incumbent upon them we need to protect
their right to kill babies in the womb
because and to disproportionately kill
babies in the womb now you know who's
during that white supremacist they are
very happy to see black and brown babies
die in the womb
and there are more black babies every
year who are aborted in new york city
than are born in new york city
and you can hear the white supremacist
cheering
the notion that it is a it is an
inherent good for black and brown women
to disproportionately kill their unborn
babies is very weird but put that one
aside i want to focus in on this this
just shows what a matt i keep saying mad
lib because it really is it makes no
internal sense corey bush here is saying
i'm thinking about the queer people
who are disproportionately affected by
an abortion man i'm gonna need an
explainer on this one
truly i'm gonna need an explainer on why
lesbians are disproportionately affected
by an abortion ban are lesbians
accidentally getting pregnant at an
outsized rate
how about like gay people and
transgender people
is that happening a lot
really is it disproportionately
affecting the queer
i'm gonna need some sort of
i'm going to need some sort of
understanding of how that works
according to corey bush
but it doesn't mean it doesn't matter
again everything they don't like is
about inequity
because they don't want to get to the
root of the issue which is that they are
fine with killing the unborn right that
really is what it is some people are
honest enough to do it mostly it's
euphemisms so the new euphemisms of the
day are not women's rights it's not safe
legal and rare the new euphemism of the
day is it's inequitable inequitable and
it affects all the same people that
every inequitable policy affects
including people who are gay who are not
getting pregnant accidentally because
that's not physically possible if you
are engaged in homosexual activity
that's not how any of this works
so
i just i found that hilarious and
self-contradictory but
again none of this has to make any sense
did you know that every single like
creates one additional leftist tier that
is just science
[Music]